what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna watch today a
first time watching put Dungeons and
Dragons
joined by someone who's been coming this
channel for years now the Tara Eric
Sentara how's it going dear hi I'm good
did you hear my dragon more while you
were talking yes it's called solid grade
A improv skills right there bring in the
a game today thank you so much ladies
and gentlemen follow Tara on her own
YouTube channel she does reactions there
herself as well it's the only way to
keep her coming back if she doesn't get
more followers she doesn't see any value
in being I'm out of here not even
friendship and make up for it guys you
know what to do leave a like on this
video that would mean a lot Tara what do
they do with that Bell and ring the bell
ring the bell also full-length Reaction
watch along is where you single with
your own copy of Dungeons and Dragons
honor amongst these is available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
thank you to all who have joined us
there so far we've gotten so many
pledges we've been doing so many movie
reactions over there and your support
means the world to cover a bunch of
stuff exclusively over there with
reaction highlights and watch along's
included talking really fast without
want this intro to be too long but I
wanted to say too thank you everyone
about a space baby shirt from the real
rejects shop zeroedition.com love it we
have sold so many it's on track to
becoming our new number one bestseller
and this rejects headband is a prototype
testing it out right now currently this
current one squeezing my head a little
too tight
I might have to be rejected
oh my God yes
let's watch this Tara let's do it
[Music]
I didn't ask have you ever played D no
never I played it one time a year ago so
all Easter eggs flying over our heads
today I don't even remember the trailer
for this one I had been invited to the D
and D session I didn't really want to
play but it ended up being a lot of fun
oh there's like a beast in there oh yeah
well what is that
whoa oh sweet hello sir that's hoga I'm
edgin and you are I've been in low cells
never shared one with a female think I'm
gonna like it oh holga doesn't love to
be disturbed while she's eating her
potatoes kind of the highlighter for day
son of you we could be very happy
I'm gonna do this without fingers and
make it a mitten
not expecting his knees to snap back
like that that was that would look great
I noticed that Chancellor Jonathan is
not present should we perhaps wait
Chancellor Jonathan was delayed by the
storm you may be surprised to learn I
wasn't always a thief
years ago I became a member of the
Harpers faction my wife Zia supported my
decision stop bandits in their tracks
and even bring fan red Wizards to
Justice
Temptation I'd come home to my loving
wife and daughter Kira with the goal I
just stole when you were a Harper you
were bound to make enemies and sometimes
those enemies come looking for Revenge
oh no
shoot oh
did they kill the the child too I don't
hear it
uh where where
oh thank goodness
oh what a good baby the baby was able to
stay quiet during this murder
Cooperative baby
[Music]
no Clara can repair the damage from a
red Wizard's blade there was no way to
revive her the red wizard oh he's
scarred now astute to observations Tara
Eric's
I'm sorry it's just hard to relive this
without Jonathan here
[Music]
that's when I met hoga
we quickly became like brother and
sister with a relationship built on
trust and mutual respect
we tried something new
[Music]
honor among Thieves
you may be wondering how we could carry
on this criminal lifestyle with a young
girl at home
well we didn't leave her at home
we also added Simon a so-so sorcerer a
con man named Forge who pushed us to aim
even higher
oh [__] you regret
when we met the wizard sophina that she
wanted our help in robbing Corn's keep
that's a Harper stronghold I don't know
if you've heard of it I'm sure Jonathan
has
[Laughter]
Forge told me that among the relics and
Corn's keep there was a tablet of
Reawakening capable of bringing back a
single deceased person you can probably
see where this is going yes
[Music]
she's handy oh
she's cool
whoa what a neat effect
[Music]
is too powerful
foreign
[Music]
the effects and designs in this movie
are so good pretty dope please wait for
Jonathan oh awesome oh he's cool
she's throwing potatoes oh
dude
oh my goodness
[Music]
I hope they didn't just kill that bird
no not Jonathan his weird name should
live on forever I like how they'd
established the dynamic between Chris
Pine and Michelle Rodriguez it's just
like a brother and sister Dynamic it's
like us Greg you could be your sister
you could you could be my very very much
much much older sister
sure
where do you think Forge took her
glue
of course is
never Wonder
oh what a dick
oh that was awesome cool have you seen A
Wrinkle in Time no well Chris Pine going
back to his daughter after trying to do
something right but being lost another
similar type of character setup it's
like a blend of that character with his
character from Wonder Woman oh
yeah he's so funny in Wonder Woman
oh
what the hell what's going on there
obviously I couldn't give back the
treasures we'd stole it Lord nevermber
fairly ill I seized the chance to try
and couldn't have done it alone and here
she is oh I knew it
she's the one that got us caught not
true no without her we all would have
been caught and since then she has
become my top advice
sneaky business
of course that's right
no it wasn't for me it was for that
tablet of riches it it's a tablet of
Reawakening I wanted to bring your
mother back I know how much you crave
for forgiveness but I promise you more
lies is not the what an [__] but you
can't blame the poor girl for
distrusting you you have been lying
since you set foot in the room haven't
you what you grant is the villain I was
doing it for Mom for all of us you have
to trust me he told me to trust you when
you left me this is a pickle I don't
think I will be returning it or your
daughter bastard
daughter for uh
handsome boy what do you clean it with
you're about to lose your head this is
what you're concerned with
if you wouldn't mind
boiled linseed oil
let's do it
[Music]
oh yes oh
yeah I just said the fact that I get rid
of this oh my God
oh she is awesome oh my goodness she is
so cool
[Laughter]
oh [__] yes
it's cool that ballet belongs with her
I should probably go speak to him no
he's gone my dear he's gone
the fact that you see good in me makes
me believe that there might just be
something
I don't know Praise on her innocence I
hate it the days of rom-com Hugh Grant
are gone straight up villain now Bay
we have to get into that castle and take
her out ourselves we're gonna need a
team goddamn right we have nothing to
pay them with Forge does he said the
richest people were coming to bed on the
high Sun games I think cure will know we
abandoned her for the right reason I
wouldn't put it like that
Simon's a terrible sorcerer I'm sure
he's got me better no one can hold a
candle to this trick
[Laughter]
I don't really like this uh cool smart
fan sneaky
is that
don't drop it don't drop it no no that's
so much gold
get him
[Music]
whoa
damn cool
oh
[Music]
that was awesome this movie shot so well
like
insane there's such good style to it and
I love how there's like a great blend of
practical and visual effects Doric she's
truly One of a Kind Joe Justice cannot
be killed on my command you're
good that's not Dory
whoa
I
oh [__]
so cool that's her
[Music]
oh that's what you want to date oh
oh okay much better much better
yeah get it ladies she looks like Sophia
lillis from uh it but I don't know about
surf oh no I think that is her is it her
yeah I'm not sure that if it's not she
has a doppelganger we're gonna take down
Ford Fitzwilliam you're the only one who
can get into that castle tell us what
we're dealing with as you can imagine I
don't trust humans finding you to be a
little man
exactly that you bring to this I'm a
planner you've already made the plant so
what valley do you have now
so you make plans that fail
Ure
I love the tone of this movie
disciple I rely on most oh the eyes no
ah spooky
if the alarm is raised nobody gets in or
out and then bug is a spy The Vault
itself
it is protected by the Arcane seal of
modern Canaan what okay a big big strong
what does that mean big strong seal is
what it means a wild shape is Among Us
whoa
oh she couldn't catch it it's too small
for you
oh damn shape-shift oh cool
it was her okay that's awesome
whoa cool Dale there's one hell of a
shot
foreign
[Music]
what a hell of a shot awesome just keep
it in the POV when shit's attacking too
that's great
oh yes yes cool
oh what
oh
she could have waited till you got out
of the house girl what an impressive
sequence
turns one of the birds yeah
oh no that's cruel no meanie damn how
can she detect it she's a sense it
oh awesome the deer
oh I got like oh no no no no no no no
damn
I got arm chills so there's no way to
open it well if we had the Helm of
disjunction it's a helmet that disables
all nearby enchantments but it doesn't
matter the thing went missing ages we're
done find it search for helmet now I
have this token that lets me ask corpses
some questions and then they go back to
being dead after the evermore's thank
you Simon for the drinks I was told this
movie was funny I wasn't told how cool
yeah this movie's rad yeah this is a
like a rock and roll Adventure man I
have not been bored once yeah
murder them
all right bye
they do a lot of long shots where they
stay in it and they don't do a lot of
tattoos and I adore that I adore it too
I just feel like these Epic Fantasy
Adventures nowadays are so like serious
and doom and gloom and imagine just to
be like really fun but also honor the
genre yeah and also has heart to it like
it's realistic which I like super
enjoyable it's like swashbuckling
oh God is that proudly Cooper yeah he's
so tiny tiny Bradley I'm surprised the
first time we met him
I thought your sentence was longer it is
I see you still have that walking stick
I gave you yeah well you could you could
take it with you if you want Quinn's not
much for rambling Glenn yeah
oh you know when you left I lost my
family I've been fortunate enough to
find another and I wish nothing less
than that for you this is so hot but it
works
we're going to take down Forge I'm gonna
show Marlon man and the elk track they
were fools to let me go she got the
closure
sort of oh she got it
she's ready now
[Music]
I love them together they are amazing
together
they make such good best friends
once the dead man is revived we can ask
him five questions at which point he
will die again never to be re-revived
you should write down your five
questions yeah before asking he prepared
maybe I'm not saying it
oh my god wow one more question right
yes no that wasn't for you did that
count as a question no oh my God
only answer when I talk to you okay oh
my God why did you say Okay at the end
of that I didn't
oh my God that was great oh my God
we knew we outnumbered them but our
advantage meant nothing against the
dragon Ray cool
Dungeons and Dragons
why aren't you gonna ask him the last
three questions
what's your favorite food
S no barley what's two plus two I bad at
math
[Laughter]
I assumed the order
God I love the Aesthetics to deliver the
helmets to our swiftest Rider then we
can just make it over the ridge
that'll do it there was the morning of
the battle
that's all stepped up my ball my foot
slipped on the stone oh no
[Laughter]
then's my brother it's not all right
it's very like Edgar Wright Cuts yeah a
little bit great transitions I just
needed to keep the helmet safe
it was a fan
who bought the mark of zast Tam
I waited for the killing blow I said
Bridgerton guy yeah
sorry
as I died he promised to keep the helmet
safe
the helmet's a dead end will have to
find another way into the world no I've
heard of zinc
the fans are murderers
you're gonna have to overcome it man I'm
still alive what's your favorite book
test question right guns of historical
Works I'd say
that was only the fourth question oh no
no
please be alive in a post credit scene
let's cut back to him I want it
wow cool oh my god oh that's a big kitty
the variety in this movie
look at that that is so awesome
oh
that's so sweet
oh that's so cute hey go talk to him you
know I've pulled cats out of fish
you know what this movie has a Whimsy
and wonder
nothing either of us have nope never
have in our lives our reasons for
launching the helmets are entirely Noble
I'm gonna Rob some poga portraits
William and the red wizard of day is
partnered with come with me
all right hot Bridgerton I'll go
wherever you go he's a very attractive
male specimen all his fellow rulers
Tam had a plan of his own
to Stage an Unholy coup
wow
man that's an awesome shot oh my God
does it suck in all the bad juice
cool enslaving them to his will
with the aid of his red Wizards zastam
created an army of the undead so there's
like a [__] ton of red Wizards what will
become of the wealthy burgle all divided
amongst the townspeople place your hand
on this Harper's seal and swear that you
will indeed distribute all the wealth
you take amongst the people of
Neverwinter character
give forges money to the people of
Neverwinter you may not yet believe your
words but I do good for you Simon hold
on
why would you put it down there because
it's just the last place that anyone who
values their life would go sounds lovely
quite the opposite I know I was being
ironic I find irony is a blade that
could see who wields it most of special
I saw firsthand the horrors of the spell
Honorable Men turned to monsters parents
turning on their own child
damn that is beloved
all right
ah oh the tiny just a tiny bit let's see
[Music]
this movie's so composed who would have
thought
some oh so lived in they've stunned
their targets and consumed the brain
taking control of the body the higher
the intelligence of the prey the more
likely they are to strike fascinating
cool
little walking brains oh gross gnarly
oh that's a little hurtful yeah
like it didn't even sniff me
there was a precise formula we must
follow so as not to trigger the
mechanism starting from the center use
odd numbered blocks only moving forward
with each step except for every fifth
step which must be a lateral move
so it's very dangerous it's a dragon
Prince
odd numbered blocks only however at the
midpoint we switched to even numbers
[Laughter]
thank you
I may have
put my foot on the bridge
can't you just magic us across
come on you can do it confidence
believe in yourself
why did you get that
what Marlon's walking stick that's not a
walking stick
it's a hither stuff cool
they got lucky
did the
it works
they got really lucky yeah
this thing that you were protected with
your very life
I will
it drops
[Laughter]
that's great oh that's where they all
are the red Wizards
or the converted Army of the Dead yeah
they have assassins or that oh took a
lot of wrong guesses we were wrong
leave them to me
oh nice oh he's got this whole thing
handled
oh [__] nice
[Music]
or about hogar oh come on
awesome awesome sick
[Music]
oh oh yeah
quickly no thank you okay so they are
the r they are they are right here yeah
what
was that Dragon I hope so
oh is it an owl what is it what it is oh
my god
oh whoa
is it a really fat dragon yeah I think
it's an overweight Dragon that's one
Punchy dress yeah you must have found a
new Den did he eat the last one
oh my God
it is so fast slide
[Music]
thank you
oh nice
whoa cool wow these perspective shots
are crazy
four big dragons
[Music]
big ass
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
that poor Dragon didn't do anything
wrong it was just a fat dragon there's
just a Fat Track
[Music]
so are we
go inside its mouth and come out the
other end
[Music]
shaking off his Slumber
you're the planner you're the platter
he's the platter
cool
smart must feel like a warm bubble bath
right about now who would not recommend
this movie idiots yeah anyone who didn't
recommend it certified get out yeah
it's just way too inventive This Is
Where I Leave You Wish you every success
on your jet what you're so essential and
you're so hot
it's gonna walk back he's just gonna
walk back and keep being unfunny
line oh wait a minute he's coming up on
a rock is he gonna go around nope
right over the Rock
oh that's hilarious they wrote that in I
love it
oh
there he is the great Simon Omar
oh my great great grandfather
it chooses whom I wield it so I'm in
I'll try a different approach great you
got this you got it
[Laughter]
[Music]
I've never seen a bigger coward
oh this poor guy's just grieving
so I'm trying to capture it
you just have to let it go
exactly exactly there's a metaphor for
you
um
this is exactly what I told you would
happen back at the tavern but you
wouldn't listen instead of dwelling on
what went wrong and who lied to whom
let's put our heads together and figure
out a plan I'm gonna figure out my way
home yeah I'm going to
guys guys
all cannot be lost we're not done until
my daughter's safe don't you sick of
failing no that's
that he must never stop
never stop we failed that's actually not
bad true failure rate of success I lost
everything that ever mattered to me and
it was all my fault one who really
killed my wife
I agreed I did
I decided we deserved a better life than
a Harper's oath would allow us oh
he called it but I didn't know that red
Wizards marked their treasure
I led them right to our door failed all
of you which is exactly why I can't quit
so if you'll excuse me I'm gonna go sit
on this rock
make a plan
that's why you got to give the money to
the townspeople we put the portal on
something and then sneak that thing into
the Vault but there'd be dozens of
guards yeah but the guards would be
guarding against people taking things
out of their wagons not putting them in
oh God could kiss you that's right
hmm
[Laughter]
Cool Chris Pine really is perfect in
these kind of rules yeah that insanely
good looking funny guy
everything a man or a woman wants is
basically yes
smart they're getting clever on knowing
how to use this device
oh
that almost made me a little seasick but
I still loved it
no no no no
oh no oh I'm Boulder hurry hurry
oh this is so creative cool
wow this movie has to have like 95
runtime right yeah give me a break it's
so cool it's so good it's so imaginative
and there's real like Stakes too
[Music]
great
now he can do magic you know damn well I
can't attune to the thing that's not
true you're the gravity of a whole
theater it was wild magic and that only
happened because they were going to kill
me exactly
you need an emotional pull you're backed
into a corner
fight or flight baby
use this to keep in contact it is a
setting Stone
oh of course like a walkie-talkie
oh let's celebrate glasses well once we
can tend to
end that's a real voice I think so
celebrate lasses
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's so cool
Ah that's painful
[Music]
just a minute
that's so cool
oh
dope
ah she didn't even need the helmet
yourself
or death time you're a Spain on your
family name so how with my name let me a
tune you had your time now it's my turn
I won't allow it I don't care whoa whoa
sorry
had to happen
what the hell took you long enough there
we go cool
just had to stand up for yourself kid
hell yeah oh man
all right well done
[Laughter]
great I made it inside the Vault so did
we where are you where are you
what
oh oh is he like he's like moving on the
oh
he left me I know you think I'm a liar
and a bad father but
I am
I am a bad father
and I wasn't trying to bring your mom
back I was trying to bring my wife back
is that his daughter it's not his
daughter no or oh it's a dark person
that was actually really well done CGI
effect when she can transform I hope you
can take comfort in knowing that she's
with the father she deserves I don't
want to see you die which is why put him
in the games
if you're gonna kill us at least let us
die with dignity put us in the ice on
games yes
yeah
I saw guards loading everything onto a
ship he was stealing it for himself you
never cared about being Lord that just
gave him access to the Vault he must
have brought back the game so the take
would be bigger smart guy if Forge is
leaving what does sophina get out of
this
a bigger Army he does have like an
Indiana Jones quality about him huh yeah
so we just go through the maze I guess
till we reach the cage
[Music]
oh
cool weapon
get it get it
keep moving yeah oh
[Music]
that's not fair uh sneaky
[__]
[Music]
oh yeah that's right
poor tongue
oh yes
oh another minute I would have lost my
hand yeah but look what you did lose
come on everyone get your hands in there
yeah if we survive this will be another
challenge in another until every last
person in that cage is dead if we have
to find a workaround
when we hear the gong when we jump in
you want to end up like that guy we'll
only be inside for a few seconds
if we're all inside he's gonna pull us
out I will trust me always always hold
hold what's the [__] plan
go
oh
Smart Genius
[Music]
get out of there cool get out of there
I've never liked a snake more I hate
snakes
you said a second that's dangerous
so smart
we gotta move
that is actually kind of scary
quite a second date yeah it's
hi honey it's the tablet of Reawakening
Kira it's the reason why I left you go
home bring back Mom
we can be a family again you can't bring
her back you're not taking my money
put down the tablet and get off my ship
that took a turn he knows I'm prepared
to do terrible things to get what I want
even to those I care about most
in the end evidently but
ah
[__]
oh my God
I've been fun
oh my God you're Magic
I hope you can swim buddy
awesome that much Dragon action huh I
mean the fat dragon was cool
but you're right
oh my God they're all gonna turn into
the her army with the red juice oh boy
the red juice on me coming in
uh yeah that's a lot of red juice
Neverwinter
come on come on he knows what to do
become the suicide squad
oh
you red Wizards oh man
pretty choke on her own greed
what is this
oh
no way awesome
oh that's fantastic you could hurt
someone
put a helmet on yeah
it's smart get the mail out of the
Coliseum yeah that's really smart just
did
use your pendant
[Music]
oh my God
gee go and then get the final blow
okay girl you're destroying your city
you know Overkill there's there's just
four of them right there I mean come on
now
wow cool
all right
she missed nope nope she created a
dragon oh
it's Kong versus Godzilla this is always
the girl saving the guys in this movie
and I love it
[Music]
take it up come on show you're more than
a planner you can do it
yeah good plan
no no no
oh my God his back's gonna get so
scratched up
nice the littlest things I love it oh
gross
yes yeah sorcerer
wow what a intricate design so damn
[Music]
oh [__]
Super Smash Brothers hands
[Music]
no no don't why would you just try to
run away oh no come on
[Music]
oh you can catch yourself cool kind of
still hurts I'd imagine yeah
yes yes
work together
the time stop
I'm so sorry
just as I begin to purge this place of
its living filth you dare interpose
oh
ah
sorry your breath just smells like
that's the old clothes it's bad
clever we had to distract you so Kerry
could slap on that cuff and so dork
could do this
yes
I think you got her a few more times
wouldn't hurt
[Laughter]
yes I've actually really becomes the
animals
you gotta be [__] me no
you not killer off
it's a red Wizard's blade
there's nothing I can do
oh he's gonna have to use the thing to
bring her if they still have it oh to
bring her back instead of the mama
promise me something
they're gonna take good care of our girl
that's her that is her mom
because he wanted to bring back
his wife not his mother not her mother
but bring back the mother I need you
yep oh that's so sweet
[Music]
the mom was there for her all along this
is such a kid movie
I love it so much
[Music]
time you have to let it go Center shots
don't tell me you wasted it on me
that's so touching
hmm I wonder if you'd consider having
another go at it
yeah all right yeah
yeah all right
he's got his whole family back lord
nevermber finally came too
his first official Act was to award the
saviors of Neverwinter the medal of
heroism nice he granted formal
protection of their people and their
land
pardon denied
session is adjourned
Jonathan
poor Jonathan
um
Bravo that was brilliant
that was so good
that was yeah I cried a little bit at
the end yeah
all right
only got 15 minutes
well this guy had an appointment to get
to break it down then I mean you could
take it away first Tara what what'd you
love about it I love
everything I love the cuts uh the Edgar
Wright moves I love that they have big
long shots but I also love there's some
way
there's not a lot of movies that I think
can add comedy action and heart into the
same movie and make it all seem grounded
like you believe the moments and they're
not like overly corny I feel like all
these moments everybody got a moment
where they got to prove themselves or
get like closure or find family and
I believed all of it like there wasn't a
moment where I was like that's a little
heavy-handed like why would they write
that in
um yeah yeah all of the moments where
they had to go and seek a thing and get
it for themselves and their heart and
their soul was
bingo
yeah I think you're a hundred percent
right on the money when it comes to this
one because I know I said during the
reaction while I catch her name really
quick is this Sofia it is it 100 sure
um yeah because like they set up a great
villain in this and this is the kind of
movie that could have easily just been
one that wanted to lean into just being
a comedy more so than anything else but
I thought they did an amazing job at
really really elevating it with the
comedy and allowing it to be something
have a unique voice amongst the fantasy
epic genre where he usually is it does
all those things of like sprawling
Adventure a lot of locations a lot of
different creatures some good action
scenes are we getting a scene that's
coming in right now I think there is
yes I win
[Laughter]
can somebody please ask me another
question
anyone yeah
there's no way it played out I was like
that's like a post-created scene I love
it
um yeah I think that when it I do oh if
they're if if they're recommending
another movie to watch that must mean
there's no post credit scene we'll let
it play just in case
um yeah the who's also gonna say you
were foreign
the women never listen
oh no you were talking about
you were talking about uh the the action
in the in the um fantasy world moving
into the action all that stuff you were
trying to like was I yeah I was so
distracted by my victory that I just had
it just flew right out of your brain
yeah that is where you were headed I
mean like we don't I've literally played
it once and the the game itself like
Wally can have a bunch of lore the the
kind of version I played and maybe this
is just how it always is where you kind
of just make up a bunch of stories it's
a big improv game it's a giant improv
game I think you would really like I
would love that because what always kind
of turned me off I've ever wanted a
dabble in the game was I feel like I
gotta learn a bunch of [__] I don't want
to learn but it's not that it is just a
bunch of role-playing and and it is a
hardcore improv game and I love it I I
loved it when I played it that one time
I just haven't hung out with my friends
who gain who did the d d gaming nights
ever since
the amount of yeah just you and I will
make our own rules it's kind of what you
do you kind of make it you go but as uh
as with this they they brought all that
to life with the storytelling the
constant like coming up with stories and
constant story time but that just fits
with the genre so well
and they they never made fun of what the
world was they never made fun of the
genre they had like some self-aware
humor but it never wanted to like step
out of its way and wink too much at the
audience it was just right where I was
like I'm invested in the journey I think
I'm really into the Peril I'm really
into what the consequences are here and
I I care about the characters like when
Michelle Rodriguez was about to die at
the end I totally forgot about the the
item to that it could bring her back I
was like what and then they planted the
seed so well with that line that he had
and they don't even remind you they
don't even they don't do the exposition
of saying right which I enjoy they like
let's let the visual language just
handle it for you right yeah I thought
that was great the the four main players
were awesome they all had uh especially
the the like the girl Sophia Lewis
doesn't have like a big character or she
gets to have her cathartic moment but
the other three have their arcs and
especially coming the wrap around
because yeah the little girl did not
know her biological mom right this was
her this was the mom she grew up with
and especially for having the Dynamics
of that between between uh in a movie
like this is usually they would be the
ones who end up together like there's no
romantic story other than the fact of
Chris Pine grieving uh over his wife
there's no actual romantic story that of
him courting anyone in this movie you
know right which is nice for a change
because you don't really have to and hot
Bridgerton guy was not courting anyone
either but he is like he's good Justice
he has some good Justice good Justice he
does good he's good Justice the
production design Tara amazing that was
shut up that one long shot
I couldn't with that I was like how does
it how do you even think of that and to
weave in and out like I'm always so
curious how they design that how they
can shoot it there's obviously going to
be hidden Cuts between graphic design
and actual camera moves and I'm always
like how do they figure it out
yeah it was sprawling and swashbuckling
throughout it just had that
that sense of adventure you don't really
get that much from I don't feel like you
really get that just genuine sense of
fun adventure yeah anymore you know I
kind of reminds you like when I saw
Pirates of the Caribbean the first time
at the theaters just that like fun
adventure with like that modern day
sensibility but it's like it's a
different time period
um and this leans much more to like
fantasy of course uh yeah I thought this
was a really just genuine great time and
Chris Pine is like so perfect in these
girls he's so perfect
him and Michelle man
I like it yes she gets to show off some
like comedic sensibilities as well here
uh where she usually is just kind of
like nowadays I see her more like she's
more just tough and here she gets to be
she got the best fight scenes
she's such a badass
yeah so cool great choreography all
around oh I loved and especially how the
women were always saving the men because
like the back of the day it's always a
man saving a woman and like from the
very first fight it is both of the women
who save the men I mean they help out
and whatever but for the most part and I
like that yeah and they don't like draw
a bunch that's true there's like no real
Damsel in Distress in this movie No
thank goodness like we don't need it
like everyone should just be strong and
cool yeah and we don't really need even
the daughter wasn't like they didn't put
her in it of course when she was like
about to have her throat cut by mean man
yeah Dylan man but other than that
um everyone was smart and competent
which I like they didn't ever turn to
the camera either to be like I don't
need a man saving me right now right
like I wasn't even thinking about her
until you like pointed it out like oh
yeah that's true look at them just kick
a bunch of ass yeah I love it and the
editing was so good too such impressive
editing there's like so many shots in
this movie and it doesn't feel like
overwhelming or over stimulating it it
no it feels it's a smooth ride it's
[Music]
[Laughter]
I wish we were certified critics so we
could try to get that on the poster it's
like a catalog
I'd probably be in the theater look at
that poster means what is it it's like a
Cadillac let's look at the rotted
Tomatoes what would you give the
percentage of this okay I am giving it
95 I really had a great time I did not
find any issues with it but again I
haven't played the game so if y'all are
DND like and it didn't deserve that
purpose 100 I'm like yeah but just look
at it as a film please give me a break
it was great it doesn't feel isolating
at all as people who don't know like
really what the game is all about
because I just played some I didn't go
into like diving in lore kind of [__]
when I played right and so like to not
be familiar with the game really it
doesn't feel like it's I it isolates or
there wasn't anything happening here
going I don't know
I don't know you know like there didn't
feel like there was a ton of Easter eggs
that we were just like missing yeah and
they knew how to handle expositions so
well where I was never lost on what was
happening in this movie despite a bunch
of new names a bunch of new worlds a
bunch of new creatures and stuff it was
a bunch of new stuff and it it never
felt like I'm playing a game of trying
to keep up they managed to just imbue
everything within the the heart and the
soul of the journey the entire time
right yeah it's a solid ass movie I I
don't know what I
I don't know what I would would don't
like about it I can't that's what I was
saying I'm like there's nothing that I
didn't enjoy because I like that the
women were saving the guys there wasn't
a ton of exposition there was a lot of
Comedy that was done really well in
regards to the pacing the heart never
felt like where they were trying to give
even when Michelle Rodriguez goes in to
get closure it's like you kind of it's
not it doesn't feel like ah they added
this in and it's not working it it
worked and it it I just yeah there's no
there wasn't any problems with it for me
ah yeah I guess uh
I felt the stakes but I guess I would
have liked a clearer sense of the
villain I don't know I feel like I'm
just looking for something that I didn't
really think double villain yeah there's
like a little like villain on top of
villain and then yeah it's like I feel
more
I feel more personal hatred towards Hugh
Grant than you did the the crazy red
witch lady yeah yeah where she was like
the real threat
um but I I felt more towards huge I
don't know I guess my there's a slight
imbalance of where to place my dislike
and I'm really kind of just looking for
something
really searching right now and I think
he can be done with it let's see what it
got I would I would give it like a 95 to
tell you the 97 okay just a one up here
click it let's see click it come on now
91. holy [__] that is yeah absolutely
awesome it deserves it heck yeah man 93
audience great that's what I mean man I
was watching it and I'm like who would
not who are the who okay how many
critics they're 286 critics 27 who are
you 20. he's 27. who are you has sons of
[__] they can't understand great
camera work and fun adventure escapism
just overwhelming dear Lord of the Rings
not go what
Source materials something that's built
on imagination creativity but they
didn't sense much of in honor among
Thieves I found the experience a bit
mundane I'm like what do you do on a
daily basis to where you uh do you think
this movie is mundane I'm like are you
just jumping out of planes every day and
like writing stuff about movies but like
the
self-conscious I thought this movie was
so confident what I don't know who these
words I don't know who you people are I
don't trust any of you here I don't
trust any of you I I love this movie you
guys this movie's great yeah I was like
a crazy they can get out of here the
critic the audience score is insanely
high on it too as it should be yeah
great fantasy Adventure man and uh it
looks awesome too from beginning to end
so did hop Bridgerton he looks great too
he was Charming I I didn't I never
finished Bridgerton I only got five
episodes into the first season everyone
says it's season two is when it gets
great it does it gets moving it gets it
gets grooving I don't yeah I just
couldn't get through the first season I
was like the same my jam
I thought those two people were awful
yeah is he in season two yeah okay and
he's some hot stuff huh yeah so is Chris
Chris is super cute real funny who's
Chris you know Pine that one oh yeah
yeah yeah that Chris yeah
he's good at playing those Scoundrels
man he's so he's so good at that
he has like a very specific archetype
yeah like from Captain Kurt to this guy
he's very very specific but he could
also do [__] like don't worry darling
and everything like that but these kind
of roles are when he does Excel he's
also something like hell or high water
these kind of roles is when I think he
just absolutely he's got this like
Natural Energy and and it it really does
like command the screen but he never
what what's great about him in ensembles
is he always does he never seems like
he's trying to steal away from the rest
of the cast right he does like allow
himself to elevate yeah he's excellent
yeah absolutely excellent he's great at
connecting with others and Sophia lillis
was nice to see her here Justice Smith
also great rooting for him man what a
wonderful Fantastical world so many
different kinds of creatures I love that
it's way better than that rings of power
show so good alrighty guys well what did
you guys think about this movie did you
love it as much as Tara and I had an
absolute blast with this one
um I hope they make a sequel did it do
all right at the point
that's the last thing we'll check did it
Duo right at the Box off I hope it's
like a huge enough streaming hit that it
at least allows for a sequel
domestic attack
great so far huh
I mean yeah let's do that correct
because it came out I forgot there was
some movie that came out like a week
after that was like bound to just knock
it out of like the box office like the
release time for this
yes this is an expensive budget it's not
going to make something better it's not
looking likely
um
hopefully it becomes big enough though
because yeah that was a blast that was a
blast sorry guys well we loved it
what'd you guys think leave your
thoughts down below subscribe follow
Tara on the socials last but not least
terribly help me do it
Gabriel
what's funny about Gabriel
John and I were constantly make the
Archangel Gabriel jokes oh but then
Gabriel
was like he had a Canada with these I'm
an atheist
oh so
Tara can you shout out our atheist
friend Gabriel yeah maintaining why it's
great to to be an atheist well it's
great to be an atheist yeah it's I mean
just like believe in yourself you know
in love and friends and friendship and
like we don't need to get wrapped up in
all the other Jews so I support you 100
are the other Jews all the other Jews oh
juice
juice I thought you were saying Jews
yeah get out of here get out of here all
the other juice we don't got to worry
about it Greg okay I'm still hearing
Jews and I think that's really really
hey that's your problem you need you
need to take a back seat okay because I
have never said I don't even why do I
need no juice I use the word juice all
the time and he knows it Gregory Alba
knows how much I use the word juice and
he's choosing not to hear it so this is
this is what our friendship is ladies
and gentlemen okay
this is what this is what is that
friendship I don't I don't know that I
both lost at all times
Gabriel you don't want to be over here
okay you don't just don't get this is
not pleasant no this is not fun for
anybody I don't know why you're
supporting us all this time when we've
tried converting you to Catholicism or
Judaism this entire time
right yeah it's not a son Holy Spirit
got it and if you want to add a little
extra cherry on top amen
a Crossing between there amen okay all
right a little flame of that candle you
know what I mean get some extra points
with God in heaven okay yeah yeah
Gabriel listen it's okay to be atheist
nothing happens when you die
congratulations
I mean do we really want something I
really want something I'd rather be
nothing when all this is done just nice
and dark just like it did it's like a
blackout you just get punched blackout
you remember nothing it's done good what
do you believe when you die Gabriel what
do you think happens
maybe there's like a bright light or
something you know maybe it's not dark
it's bright it might be like nice like I
haven't you know like that kind of a
thing I don't know that's what you think
an atheist is gonna get but like it I
have it like differently like it's like
why he walks into it and then then maybe
it's blackout like it's like a TV like
static TV maybe and they find out
they're just in a Toyota car dealership
yeah that sounds atheist to me yeah and
then they gotta go like sell cars but
they're like I'd rather do that than be
in a weird land filled with flowers in
clouds you know
another
sell some Toyotas then
yeah lots of money
oh yeah right yeah yeah and then Gabriel
can use that money to up his pledge
exactly that would be perfect Gabriel
get get in there sell some sell some
more car car cars and get some more
juice
again Canon we're talking about the Jews
we don't need that kind of heat on us
friendship we got three people here who
come on now who are Jewish it's tough
this guy it's tough he really he it's
not something he he he he just pushes me
into a corner and then he's just like I
hope you can find your way out
that is not a good thing to say about a
man publicly on the internet
I do not push Tara into corners and
threaten her
support
with his words
alrighty you've earned your solid two
and a half hours according to this timer
Tara see you guys soon thanks Gabriel
for being here
[Music]